you just made a very important
observation some scripts don't modify
the Dom or the CSS on and really this
shouldn't block rendering and analytics
is a great example yeah I wish we had
some way to tell the browser exactly
that actually we can one strategy would
be to load the script after the page is
loaded so when the browser fires the
onload event and we could execute the
script then all right how would I do
that the browser fires an onload event
when the page is finished loading and
you could wait for that and then execute
your script then check the instructor
notes for instructions on how to do that
okay will do anything else yeah the
onload technique is a good one to have
in your back pocket but there's actually
an even simpler strategy that we could
use all we need is an extra attribute on
the script tag let me show you cool I've
pulled out our Analytics code into a
separate file and added the async
attribute to the script tag this
attribute has two important properties
first it tells the browser that it does
not have to block Dom construction when
it encounters the script sack as a
result the browser dispatches the script
request and continues parsing the Dom
second the execution of the script also
does not block on the CSS object model
so if the script is available before the
CSS object model is ready it can still
be executed right there and then oh wow
that's handy
so async basically means that the script
does not block the critical rendering
path exactly the browser will download
and execute the script but it won't
block the parser and it won't block on
CSS what about inline scripts can I put
an async attribute on an inline script
unfortunately that wouldn't work inline
scripts will always block on the CSS
object model well with one exception if
you put your JavaScript above your CSS
then it will execute without blocking on
CSS to learn more about this pattern and
async scripts check out the link in the
instructor notes let's do a quick
exercise to see if you can spot the
difference between these patterns